Daffodil Hudson: Hello?
Yeah, this is she.
What?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, of course I accept.
What are the dates again?
Pen. Pen. Pen.
March 17 through 21.
Okay, all right, great. Thanks.
Lab Partner: Who was that?
DH: It was TED.
LP: Who's TED?
DH: I've got to prepare.
["Give Your Talk: A Musical"]
(Music)
["My Talk"]
♪ Procrastination. ♪
What do you think?
(Doorbell)
Can I help you?
(Music)
Speaker Coach 1: ♪ Let's prepare for main stage. ♪
♪ It's your time to shine. ♪
♪ If you want to succeed then ♪
♪ you must be primed. ♪
Speaker Coach 2: ♪ Your slides are bad ♪
♪ but your idea is good ♪
♪ so you can bet before we're through, ♪
♪ speaker, we'll make a TED Talk out of you. ♪
Speaker Coach 3: ♪ We know about climate change, ♪
♪ but what can you say that's new? ♪
♪ SC 1: Once you find your focus ♪
♪ then the talk comes into view. ♪
SC 2: ♪ Don't ever try to sell something ♪
♪ from up on that stage ♪
♪ or we won't post your talk online. ♪
All: ♪ Somehow we'll make a TED Talk out of you. ♪
(Music)
SC 1: Ready to practice one more time?
DH: Right now?
Stagehand: Break a leg.
DH: ♪ I'll never remember all this. ♪
♪ Will the clicker work when I press it? ♪
♪ Why must Al Gore go right before me? ♪
♪ Oh man, I'm scared to death. ♪
♪ I hope I don't pass out onstage ♪
♪ and now I really wish I wasn't wearing green. ♪
All: ♪ Give your talk. ♪
SC 1: ♪ You must be be sweet like Brené Brown. ♪
SC 2: ♪ You must be funny like Ken Robinson. ♪
All: ♪ Give your talk. ♪
SC 3: ♪ You must be cool like Reggie Watts ♪
All: ♪ and bring out a prop like Jill Bolte Taylor. ♪
DH: ♪ My time is running over. The clock now says nil. ♪
♪ I'm saying my words faster. Understand me still. ♪
♪ I'm too nervous to give this TED Talk. ♪
All: ♪ Don't give up. Rehearse. You're good. ♪
♪ We'll edit out the mistakes that you make. ♪
♪ Give your talk. ♪
DH: ♪ I will be big like Amy Cuddy. ♪
All: ♪ Give your talk. ♪
DH: ♪ I will inspire like Liz Gilbert. ♪
DH: ♪ I will engage like Hans Rosling ♪
♪ and release mosquitos ♪
♪ like Bill Gates. ♪
SC 2: ♪ I'll make a TED Talk out of you. ♪
♪ I'll make a TED Talk out of you. ♪
(Applause)
["Brought to you by TED staff and friends"]
(Music)